Thank you.
Maybe we can do some introductions.
All right, I'll start since my list is kind of short.
My name is Rick.
So rich.
I am the engineering manager here at DAS.
And I work directly with Dan Aston, which I believe you guys have met previously.
I can start on my end.
So I'm Leo.
I'm the manager of this here group of misfits.
And we do computery things on the internet at a high level, you know, build things, AI,
cloud, all the likes.
I'll drop it over to Alicia.
Well, we talked a little bit before, Alicia, and I'll be working with the data stuff here.
Hello, my name is Luis.
I am a computer engineer.
And yeah, basically, we do everything, you know.
Hi.
Yeah.
My name is Sid.
I'm one of the software engineers and avid fishkeeper.
So it's really nice to meet you.
Hey, finally, me.
I'm Julio.
I am also a software engineer.
I'm ready to do anything.
Awesome.
It's nice to meet all of you.
All right.
So where would you guys like to start?
Possibly an overview, lay of the land with me.
All right.
I will share what I've got here.
So we have a bunch of SSIS jobs.
That's kind of hard to read here.
As you can see, they're very tightly coupled, and they run in different intervals.
Basically, a lot of times they will drop tables, truncate them all together, and then rebuild them from scratch,
which is one of the issues with fragility, you know, because if anything crashes,
now we just have a whole table that's missing.
But you can kind of see here, this is the high-level list of the jobs that we have.
Hopefully, you guys can read that.
Got my glasses on now.
But you can see they basically take a pretty predetermined amount of time to run,
and we stagger them out a little bit because one job might be dependent on a previous job,
so very tightly coupled in that way.
So for like a little bit of a better visual, this is the current status of the jobs right now.
So you can see this is the job that's running currently,
and you can see all the ones that run previously and the ones that are coming up soon here.
And you can see here, this is kind of like a status of how they've been running,
and I actually came in this morning,
and you see that this one has already failed a couple times over the weekend.
The data engineers silently fixed it.
Whatever they did, nobody really knows, but that was the error message that we were getting.
So it's constantly breaking.
You know, we have about, I think, three or four data engineers in India
that are constantly kind of taping the thing back together
and trying everything they can to get it running stable.
Is this one built by your team?
I built this like a week or so ago.
I basically was kind of tired of not knowing what the SSIS jobs were doing,
so, you know, that has a whole set of tables and stuff with data in them,
so I basically extracted all that out so I can kind of get a better visual of what's happening at any given time,
see what job's running, any, you know, failure rates, the success rates.
Like we found that this one job has never run successfully.
I don't know why we even have that in there,
but you can see that it's pretty common for them to just randomly fail,
and then the engineers fix them without really telling us.
So it's not the ideal, you know, for modern times.
There's a lot of better ways of doing this than SSIS.
So should hopefully give you somewhat of a high level of what we're dealing with here.
Job description, each job description here is what I kind of extrapolated from this.
Some of them I don't know what they do.
I'm assuming this just builds this report for the CDXP customers, CDXP being the name of the product.
You know, this is extracting all of the appointments from different CRM providers.
You know, not sure what the customer value one is.
I believe it just, I had AI try to determine what these job descriptions were,
because getting these descriptions from the engineers is also like pulling teeth.
But, yeah, this kind of gives you a pretty high level of what we're dealing with here.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, go ahead.
Are these jobs committed to a repo or a code somewhere, or do they only live in SSIS?
They are.
We have all of the SQL stuff committed to a repository,
and we actually have some of it scattered into AWS.
So we will have AWS monitoring SFTP for when a new file gets created,
and it then pulls in the file and then dumps it into a location and then triggers.
And then that next time the SSIS job runs, it will then pick up that file,
pull out all of the individual records, and start dumping it in the database.
Cool. Where does the FTP live?
Sometimes it's on our end.
Sometimes it's actually our customers' SFTP for their personal dealerships and stuff like that.
So we don't always control that, but it's a healthy mix of both.
Cool. All right. Thank you.
We have quite a lot of different databases here.
You could ignore these two down here, but these are the main ones.
So this is actually where the SSIS jobs run on this instance of EC2.
And then we have two other databases, you know, with different chunks of data.
So these jobs also ingest that from that flat file
and then store it into a raw database table and then kind of picks it up
and moves it along the chain into the different tables and databases throughout the process.
Sometimes it tacks on more information. Sometimes it calculates information.
Again, very, very brittle because when it does break, we don't really know where it breaks.
That's why it takes, you know, three engineers just to keep the thing running on a daily basis.
Are these databases on EC2 host or are they like RDS?
No, these are EC2. We have two RDS ones down here,
but this is mostly for pulling in like webhook information from emails, SMS, things like that.
And then this runs, we run Mautic.
It's an open source application for doing segmentation and emailing and stuff like that.
That was before we purchased the company.
That was what their attempt was to modernize it.
So that runs on RDS.
But generally, this is where the SSIS jobs really do their magic here.
And yes, they all run on physical servers, which take a lot of maintenance.
And again, very brittle.
They're very expensive, especially the SSIS one itself because it's so large.
Which again, I know that they've been flirting around with the idea of doing AWS Glue
to kind of make this somewhat serverless so we can downsize some of these databases.
But again, that's just somewhat throwing the problem into the cloud,
not necessarily addressing the real issue that this is just a bunch of jobs
that have been slapped together over 12 years.
Which is the, I see a DMS warehouse.
That one is a complete data warehouse or just part of it?
It's just part of it.
Generally, most of the data comes into the staging database.
And then a little bit of the data gets manipulated
and then it gets put into the target database.
And then from there, it then gets kind of sprinkled throughout,
like pulling some of the inventory, pulls out some of the analytics there.
This is where all the dealer management software stuff gets stored as well.
I'm not 100% sure about all of these databases, what these are for.
But these other ones on the top here are for different applications
for our website builder, storing all of our clients.
Some of these databases aren't even used anymore, like BirdBath.
I actually don't think Digital Bundle is either.
But I keep track of it all here because they haven't deleted them.
They're still here.
This is like a 12-year-old application and it's changed hands a few times.
So there's not been a lot of cleanup in the past as well.
So there's a lot of old artifacts that people are too afraid to delete
because they don't know if they do anything or not.
It's one of those situations too.
So the ETLs are all the jobs that you had there, right?
Yes.
You showed us before.
Yes. These are all the jobs here.
They used to take a little over 24 hours to process all of them.
They've done lots of optimizations,
indexing, things like that to improve them.
But again, it's just not a really scalable approach to begin with,
because I'm no SQL person.
I haven't had a lot of experience using SSIS jobs in the past.
So I don't know if this is best practice.
Does not really seem like it's the best way to approach this sort of thing,
mostly because of how brittle it is.
Generally, when you follow best practices and do things like that,
things typically be a little more stable than this.
So my assumption is that a lot of this is not best practice.
Do you know the size of the databases?
I'm not sure off the top of my head,
but I believe the one where the SSIS job is running is in the terabytes size.
But each database is very large because generally,
they don't really delete much other than the tables that they
truncate and then rebuild from scratch.
So we'll have old records,
especially in the ones up here in the builder where we have
old customers that we store data and we just never cleaned it up.
So all the databases are very,
very large, millions and millions and millions of records.
Do you keep the information just because in case someone need it,
or is because it is needed?
A lot of it, they just capture it all and
then just move the data that they want to use.
So what ends up being used here is what's actually used,
but down here where it gets pulled in,
I think they just keep it just in case they ever need it,
because they just ingest the whole flat file.
So there's other processes in this SSIS job that actually trigger
hitting third-party APIs to get data on the equity of those customers,
as well as recalls and things like that.
But I don't believe the SSIS jobs trigger the API calls.
The API calls dumps it in the database,
the SSIS jobs picks it up and moves it into
the permanent destination where the applications actually query it.
Which is the problem of this taking a lot of time being processed?
It's like someone needs this in real time or?
Well, a lot of this is like for example,
appointment data or sales data where they made sales.
So let's say somebody puts in an appointment for today,
or let's say even last night at an inconvenient time,
it may take a full 24 hours to pick up that change and process it.
Because once this job is run,
it's not going to run again till the next day at that time,
and if we haven't gotten it by then.
So that's another big downfall is one of these jobs fails,
it may take 24 or 48 hours for it to even fully recover and then get
that information out to the customer for
e-mail communications and SMS, things like that.
Can we have access to those jobs read-only?
Yeah, I can get you access to that.
Do you store the historicals of the data if you need to rebuild the dataset?
Some we do and some we do not.
All the files generally don't ever get deleted,
so they're usually still in there so they can reprocess them in that way.
Because they generally, when something goes wrong,
they will start over from scratch and reprocess everything.
You guys access to it.
Do you just want access to the SSIS DB,
or do you want access to all of these databases read-only?
If we can get access to the lot,
that being the more the barrier.
Yeah, not a problem at all.
To size it up. Cool. Thanks.
Yeah, then you guys will get a better idea because some of these tables,
specifically the initial staging ones where we
pull in the DMS sales and appointment data,
some of those tables are like 300 plus columns wide,
as well as millions and millions of records.
Because you have to imagine,
I think we have roughly about 200 clients on here,
and then we're pulling in every one of their customers for all time.
It gets really, really unruly.
The performance issues where we have,
we're constantly locking tables and things like that.
It's really not a surprise with just no care was taken here for performance,
which is funny that we have three data engineers working on this,
and not one of them can do much other than just keep it running.
So far, I don't have many other questions about this.
I'd really like to see what the ETLs are doing.
If you say 300 column tables, of course,
the performance is in SQL Server,
the way they do the locking, yeah, of course, no wonders.
They've solved a lot of their problems mostly by a little bit of indexing,
but mostly throwing more power at it,
more CPU, more memory,
and that gets really expensive in the Cloud at a certain point,
which is we've hit that point where now,
if we grow more customers,
if we were to happen to go from 200 customers to 2,000 customers,
this application may not be affordable and profitable to run anymore.
It's just not scaling correctly.
What's your objective midterm?
How many more customers are you planning to have or how much more are you growing?
Well, this has quickly become our flagship product for our CEO.
So she is pushing the salespeople heavily to make this
the top sale product because generally, just cost to operate,
we're not really paying any third-party providers like
Google or TikTok for ad, stuff like that.
So this is something we're pushing heavily on sales.
The unfortunate part is due to the stability and the data integrity issues,
we are seeing people off-board as well.
So as we grow,
we're also shrinking because of the stability.
So somewhat self-resolves in that sense to prevent us from scaling up,
not in a good way.
But in her mind,
she would definitely like to see it get up to the 2,000 mark as soon as possible.
Okay.
Do you have usage metrics for the app in terms of queries per second,
ops, inbound, outbound, and then traffic on intake and reads?
I can see if the engineering team has that.
I'm not sure if they do specifically about the SQL stuff.
I know we definitely have metrics on, for example,
like how many marketing messages we send out a day per client,
as well as we should have metrics on
the engagement of the customers where they're clicking on different stuff like that.
So we have those metrics,
but I'll see if I can find specific.
I imagine you guys are looking more for SQL metrics.
All sorts from application to SQL,
just that'll help paint a picture in numbers.
So that we can also think about targets.
We're talking about scaling.
So this is your current footprint and this is what's coming in and out.
If we need to scale it, there's probably that helps inform with some targets.
If we need 10x, we need to do better than that cap.
There are some tables at the end of the line,
what we call juice reporting.
I don't know if you've heard of juice reporting before.
We have a juice session later this afternoon.
Perfect. Yeah.
So basically, some of these,
we just dump all the data in whatever columns that our data engineers want,
come dump into there, and then we have
our product managers make these dashboards using juice.
Again, a lot of times,
the data engineers don't really take care of performance,
and they just select star and dump it all in that table,
which when we don't need all that data,
instead of just giving us what the product manager needs to accomplish the report,
they just throw all 300 columns in there and it's the wild, wild west.
So not great,
but fortunately, juice is decoupled from the application.
So if you're doing a large query there and it locks that table,
it's only locking that juice table report.
Nothing really affects the performance of the app,
but still not great.
Juice has not also been the greatest for us either,
with breaking changes and things like that,
and that's just another thing that goes offline for us.
Juice is not connecting to a read-only database?
It's just a regular transactional?
Okay, it is.
It's connecting to a read-only table.
That's a one-way, but every once in a while,
they push an update that breaks something or the ETLs just shove
some bad data in there and break it or truncate
a table and crash and then never rebuilds the table.
So there's a whole host.
things that go wrong there. Got it, got it. And so your final users are like self-served.
They create their own reports out of these tables? Our product managers do. So they generally make
the reports and they call them dashboards and they will give customers access to their dashboard with
just their scoped of data and that's pretty much it. I believe we even can email those reports to
them as well on a schedule. Okay, got it.
Did we also get access to, read-only is perfect, to the code for the ETLs and the jobs?
Yeah, I can get you access to the repository. I believe it's just one massive, all the store
procedures, everything. So you can actually get, actually see a better picture of their,
this job triggers this store procedure and you can see a lot of the costs.
Oh, cool. And your dashboard piece also. Yeah. The one that you have where all the jobs are
executing? Unfortunately, this hasn't been put anywhere in the cloud. This is just running
local host right now. We're still in process of getting this up into production. Maybe just
a screenshot since you already have it organized. Yeah, not a problem. I'll take some screenshots
for you. Great.
Okay, so read-only access to all the databases, gather some metrics about the application,
GitHub access for the SSIS and SQL repository all together and
screenshots of this portal right here. So far. Lovely.
All right. Not sure if you guys have any other questions for me. I know it's not very structured.
I kind of was just thrown at this and tried to, because the engineers we have aren't very
forthgiving with information. So a lot of this I've kind of had to abuse over like a year's time
of just going through and diagramming this stuff to kind of figure out how all this plugs together.
And it's quite large, you know, all the different applications, but so I'm no expert by any means,
but unfortunately I'm the one who knows the most on state side.
Got it. Can we also get a copy of the lucid charts? Yeah, I can send this over to you.
I made all of these charts. I'm just trying to understand what we have. You know, I kind of went
through the AWS account, documented this and try to figure out what triggers what and what plugs
into what. So if you have questions about the lucid charts, that's something I can answer and
I can get you more information about as well. Cool. So the DB servers aren't AWS, but the
SSIS that's in office 365 on your Azure account. No, all of this is AWS. Oh, okay. Got it. Got it.
100% AWS. We do have in our Azure account, another ETL that pulls data out of these tables into what
we call our data warehouse, which is where we run our reports off of. That's kind of not necessarily
related. We also break those reports all the time, but those are kind of not related to this problem.
Really, we just really want to scope on the AWS side of things.
I have one more question. Do you think the main issue with this is performance? Let's say that
performance is very good and everything is working. So these databases are not the problem.
I mean, it's the performance. Yeah. When I say performance, I'm talking about like more of the
system as a whole performing because I actually think they've done a lot with what they have.
And I'm sure a lot of these queries are pretty well optimized and the tables are,
as well optimized as can be. I think where a lot of the issues are is just,
the thing was designed initially, and then it's gone eight years of strapping on functionality
without actually considering the system as a whole. So I think just as a whole, the whole
concept is not really been scoped out. It's gone through engineers in Ukraine,
engineers in Mexico, engineers in India that have it now. It's changed ownership hands a few times.
So a lot of times people just kind of figured out what they could, just didn't touch the stuff they
didn't understand. So there's a lot of that in here. So kind of just is what it is. But honestly,
I think it's not so much an individual table problem. I think it's more of just
the whole process was not properly scoped, designed and architected.
So I think it's more of a big picture thing. And do you know if there is a missing data because of
a problem with the ingestion or the data is there, but it's difficult to look at it or?
Um, sometimes it's ingestion problems, because again, it's not the best design thing,
because sometimes we get these files through and like they create an email job in their
system that sends a report and then picks it up and dumps it into this SFTP.
So there's, there's a lot of faults there that can happen that we're just missing dealers data.
And we might take a month to realize that it's not been ingesting. Sometimes it's one of these
jobs breaks down midway. Um, for example, like this one, it was broken all weekend and we,
you know, so there's going to be some missing data down the line. So when it does run today,
it will repair that. But you know, if you run any reports before this job runs at 9 PM tonight,
then there will be Swiss cheese in the data, you know, in the reports.
So a lot of times we don't realize that until a customer or a product manager says, Hey,
why haven't I gotten any appointments and, you know, four weeks? And it's like, Ooh, yeah,
that stopped ingesting files a while ago. You know, it could be us, it could be them.
It could be a new column that's breaking it or, or overflowing a data field.
Any problem, possible problem you can imagine we've experienced it.
Oh, cool. Well, awesome. Um, anybody else have any questions?
Um, do you, do you want me to send access, you know, all the access you guys asked to
everybody on this call or is there someone in particular or a generic email?
Yes, we have been using das at we are conflict.com.
For, um, you know, kind of a shared login. And then we have a last pass in your last pass
organization that then sets up where we're dropping stuff in. If that is easier. Perfect. So
that'll really help. Yep. That way I can just make one login, dump it all in there for you guys,
and you guys can have at it. Precisely. And we're on the VPN and we've got the last pass
Precisely. And we're on the VPN and we've got the last pass access on our one password vault
because, you know, of course, uh, and then everybody gets access to the lot so we can
go and divide and conquer and, and, you know, poke at stuff from there. Um, I am going to set up,
um, a shared GitHub, uh, as well so that we don't have to, you know, grab everybody's, uh,
handle. And then I will, um, reply, um, to the email, although we also have a team's chat
with you, uh, where at least Dan is in there. Maybe it might be helpful to add you or start
one, but we're also on teams. So yeah, I'll have him add me into that chat. Perfect. So cool. Cool.
Well, um, this has been most helpful. Thank you so much for, for the walkthrough, the tour and,
and the access. I'm sure we're going to have a bunch more questions once we kind of get in there
and, and again, and in the meantime, like you also know how to reach out, like we, you know,
if there's anything new that pops up or whatever, um, please feel free to, to, to reach out. And,
uh, if we could get a share of the meeting when it's done recording, that'd be great. Cause we
run it through our tools to make sure that we've got transcript and notes and action items and all
that stuff. We get captured from the transcript as well. So, uh, thanks so much. All right. I will
get that over there and I assume you'll put the shared GitHub inside the last pass. So then once
I have that, then I'll share it with you guys. Yes. Um, I'll, and, uh, yep. Yep. I'll do that.
Alrighty. I will work on giving all this stuff to you guys today.
And then if you guys need anything else for me, feel free to reach out.
Thank you. Thanks so much, Rick. Really appreciate the walkthrough this morning.
Have a good rest of your day. Yes. Good meeting all of you. Likewise. Bye-bye. Thank you.
Bye.